all right North turning to some other
news now North Korean leader Kim jong-un
skipped another holiday over the weekend
adding to rumors he's sick or even dead
the 36 year old was last seen in public
April 11th
South Korea says there are no signs
anything is wrong Yong hak is a top
expert on Kim jong-un she worked for the
CIA and the National Intelligence
Council now she's at the Brookings
Institution a think-tank her new book is
called becoming kim jeong-hoon a former
CIA officers insights into North Korea's
enigmatic young dictator good morning
thanks for being with us let me start
off there have been rumors before about
Kim jong-un
so how seriously do you think we should
take these Thank You Anthony I would say
that there yes Kim has disappeared in
the past for a week or two weeks and in
2014 he disappeared for six weeks but I
think what was interesting about this
this current disappearance or absence is
that he missed one of the most important
holidays and that was April 15th his
father his grandfather's birthday and
given that he rests his legacy and his
legitimacy on his grandfather that was
certainly a red flag and we've seen some
recent reporting about his absence and
and so I think that is something to be
looking for in the future he's he's
young he's only 36 but but you described
him as an old 36 what do we know about
his health exactly well we know that
he's 30 he know we know that he's 36
he is obese and you can see from régime
just from the regime media itself that
he has gained weight over the years very
much so in the summits of the past two
years with President Trump and and other
and regional leaders had the unintended
effect of actually showing how out of
shape he is we can hear him wheezing we
can see him sweating we can see him
straining
without the soft regime filters of state
media we couldn't see that directly for
ourselves how exactly poor his condition
is and of course he also has a history
of heart disease and diabetes his
grandfather died of a heart attack at
the age of 82 his father had a stroke
and died three years later three years
later and so we have this string of of
Kim's who have that had these types of
problems but at this point we don't know
if he had heart problems or heart
surgery or anything of that sort the one
way the u.s. tries to figure out what's
going on in North Korea is by satellite
imagery a satellite image surfaced over
the weekend of a train spotted at a
coastal resort in North Korea what would
that tell us exactly as with all of the
fragmentary information that we've been
seeing the Train doesn't tell us whether
he's there or whether he's sick or what
kind of condition he is in but as that
report suggested the fact that his train
is there lends more weight to the fact
that he is that he is on the coast this
is one of his favored villas that's
where he can rest and relax and so you
know that is one other piece of
information that he might be in that in
that region you write in your book that
Kim is rational not suicidal
if there does end up being a transition
here is that likely to shake things up
in North Korea you know son it keeps
health and any leaders health for that
matter is something that the
intelligence community and the US
government looks at very closely and
especially in a society like North Korea
where there's such a personalist
dictatorship in the singular person and
I think that given given the fact that
he holds the reins in terms of the
nuclear weapons the the military and the
security apparatuses this is why this is
so important in the and the
world is looking so closely at where kin
might be and yes Kim is very rational
he's he's not out to set a nuclear
weapon against the United States and if
I were if I were him giving the fact
that he also went through a compressed
grooming process after his father stroke
that I would have been thinking about a
succession process from the very
beginning so given that his that he's
rational I think the the we shouldn't
anticipate some some big conflict to
break out but I think the fact that he
has all the reins of power we have to be
very watchful for where he might be and
if there's a prolonged leadership
struggle or vacuum in North Korea Young
pack thank you very much
her book becoming Kim jong-un goes on
sale tomorrow